[Singing]
The Black Clown is a poem by
Langston Hughes that we have adapted for
the stage with the purpose of further
explicating and amplifying his intent for
humanity to be claimed
Performing this piece and being allowed to present it
with such an incredible family of
collaborators is being empowered to make
a statement that I feel is most
important and crucial if not critical in
our world today
[Performance music]
I really hope that audiences take away
from this piece the importance of
engaging with individuals in the context
of their entire history. I think one of
the only ways that we can move towards a
better society is that they have an
understanding of where people come from
[Singing]